das hier ist mein lieblings produkt das
ist das schon so geil eingepackt und es
war halt echt das hat nur so 45 euro
kostet keine ahnung leute und ganz
wichtig wie immer ihr könnt schon
abonniert alle fleißigen kanal
wir sind bald eine million ist für mich
mehr so viele ich habe mich mega freut
ist jetzt auch direkt weiter halte das
für eine kranke begrüßung weil es mich
mal machen leute wird es jetzt mal
kurzen begrüßung noch so etwas gedacht
und dann zu einem neuen video und andres
locate etwas wieder ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja dich
hornet war zu heftig
was jetzt noch etwas gut ich hoffe mich
ganz gut hinbekommen wiedersehen greife
ich mache ja das wird schon passen so
spielen dass wir gut können lassen doch
nach oben da und wir uns schlecht von
den daumen nach unten
ich bleibe bei sätzen wie gesagt ich
hoffe euch geht's gut
heute wir haben das schon ein video
gemacht weil wir neue airport tricks
ausgepackt haben und zwar die 10.000 gws
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie die
abgeschnitten haben dann schaut euch
einfach das video an
sie liegen hier auf jeden fall jetzt
schon ich habe hier einmal meine
originalen airports und die take den
erhalt von gerade und ich habe unter
anderem auch schon in dem video
angekündigt das ist noch ein video geben
wir in dem ich airport cases auspacke
aus china amerika ich weiß wo ich
herkomme ich hab das internet ordentlich
durchstöbert und habe wirklich die
verrücktesten cases gefunden wirkliche
welt mir das erst glauben wenn nicht
seht wir haben so viele verschiedene
sachen und ich muss sagen wir laden gar
nicht lange und palenberg mal an ich bin
gespannt ob das wirklich cool aussieht
dann hatte ich habe mir noch ein paar
merkt sein also dass wir sind die
einzigen die ich noch hat die anderen
sind alle weg wurden alle verschickt
keine ahnung warum ich die nicht
verschickt habe muss ich sagen ich weiß
die musik apple kreis aber auch gar
nicht welcher es war aber eigentlich
ganz gut aus sie haben immer noch
akku gut also wir haben ja drei
exemplarisch sagen ich packte
hintereinander aus ich versuche euch
dann auch immer das produktfoto
einzublenden
und ich werde euch alle sachen in der
video beschleunigung verlinken ich habe
das irgendwie bei seinem job gefunden da
konnte man ziemlich viele davon
bestellen haben alle so zwischen 3 und 6
78 euro kostet ja ich würde sagen ich
jetzt erst noch mal rein und dann fangen
wir mal an jeweils konstant
zusammenzutun
das hier ist mein lieblings produkt das
ist das schon so geil eingepackt und es
war halt echtes hat nur so 45 euro
kostet keine ahnung passt auf ich sag
mal gar nichts dazu das packen wir am
ende aus sodass wirklich geld dann würde
ich sagen dass man hier mit anfangen
sagt schon reingeguckt ich freue mich so
wir haben hier so dumm ist sich auch
anhört ein süß saurer soße von
mcdonald's airport case also als ich das
gesehen habe dachte ich als wenn es
sowas gibt ich hätte das auch noch
bestellen können als chicken nuggets
also so ein erfolg ist als ticket und
daher freue mich wirklich dass hier okay
aber wer hat denn bitte in einem chat
airport case ja also wir machen das mal
auf guck mal hier sogar mit anhänger und
aha und dann die sonnen stereo paar
dingen bin ich mal gespannt ob das jetzt
hier überhaupt passt sagt nein damit und
den deckel drauf
es ist so genial
das ist ja so genial und dann war
erstmal kurs jetzt vergleichen wenn dir
vor jemand finde dass draußen und
meisten weg von der alten verpackungen
wird also ein bisschen ähnlichkeit ist
da würde ich mal sagen das ist zu heftig
habe es technische wie zaubers ja ja ich
weiß es ist doch egal
süß sauer leute ihr könnt auch sehr
gerne kommentieren
welches produkt er am besten findet oder
welches casey am leichtesten findet ich
werde natürlich auch alle wie immer
außer vielleicht eins auf meinem
instagram verlosen man das sorry
deswegen ihr müsst einfach auf die
antworten an
dann könnt ihr das praktisch dann
gewinnen instagram sich alex wie und das
ist schon mal ultra kein so wir haben
aber noch ein bisschen was ich glaube
ich aber insgesamt sieben stück bestellt
juli ich weiß das nächste wirst du
extrem feiern
ja ich hab's ja noch nicht verraten wenn
du willst schenk ich dir bist du bereit
super hier an
wir haben hier einfach eine trickot
pikachu erfolgt also das musste ich auch
direkt von den schwanz so als ich würde
sagen hier zu diesem schwarzen akzenten
passt ja auch dann dieses schwarze
airport case oben rein damit
und darauf ist das gute verhältnis steht
nicht mehr
doch doch obwohl das recht doch ganz
stehen halb stehen jetzt aber wofür ist
dann das hier nicht lange sollte würde
ich hab die kannst du dich kehren ja
schon von hinten sieht so aus also man
erkennt auf jeden fall dass des picacho
ist hier fällt vielleicht auch so ein
gesicht gefehlt wird aber sonst ist
meckern auf hohem niveau
freilich auch übertrieben ja geil madrid
hätte ich genauso gekauft aber das wars
natürlich tun wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten produkt also wie gesagt auch
das hier habe ich euch ja wahrscheinlich
angewendet und ist auch in der video
beschreibung verlinkt ich sag das jetzt
auch weil ich das irgendwie echt witzig
wenn das so also an allerdings bayern
kommt mir gerade wenn man das sie dann
hier auch so auf macht wobei man hier
jetzt etwas probleme hat ist in der
video beschreibung verlinkt lasst euch
nicht jungen samar einzukleben kommen
wir zum nächsten sagte warten war schon
ich es kann sein dass einst auch nicht
angekommen ist aber das nicht stimmen
als nächstes pass auf sonst wieder ran
wir haben hier ein wenig krank geiles
produkt und zwar eine coca cola dose
also ich muss sagen ist jetzt weg hat
zufällig am meisten dann die dose dann
ist okay wir müssen zuerst raus
man muss sehen wie zu hause sagt dann
dass wir sind jetzt die originalen
airports kommen überall hat man halt
auch noch dieses jahr dabei haben uns
nochmal alle festen ja wir sitzen gut
also ist auf jeden fall gut gemacht auch
hier unten ist dann immer hallplatz
damit man es laden kann
und wenn man dann ein bisschen glos hat
macht man einfach so und kann sich das
gern die steht natürlich auch die katze
auch was willst du jetzt sagen welche
findest du von den dreien am besten ich
finde es schade dass albig hat kein
gesicht
aber sonst eigentlich suite and our bis
jetzt am besten am krassesten so vom
layout okay kann ich verstehen aber alle
sind natürlich irgendwie witzig so wenn
du einen opa ist natürlich schade dass
ich jetzt nicht noch mehr airports habt
damit wir da reinkommen können
deswegen würde ich aber vor zu sagen wir
machen wir weiter
da weiß ich jetzt gar nicht was jetzt
ist endlich eingestellt
instagram yahoo
es gibt auch nichts was es nicht gibt
auch meinem canale leute deswegen lohnt
sich auf jeden fall den kanal sky
abonniert muss ich immer sagen wofür du
eine million dass irgendwann wieder
fahrgäste am anfang zu sagen also ins
alte dass das ganze gegend wo das serial
bisschen retro und so trotzdem geil ich
würde sagen bei kik hat schweini steht
machen wir den mal wieder befreien war
der immer wieder hier sagt das ist auf
jeden fall passt perfekt und jetzt muss
ich dann sieht das genauso geil
das ist das erste instrument was es gibt
aber
an sich so feiere ich auch übertrieben
also ich kann gar nicht sagen mit bis
jetzt alle geil
mir gefällt die vor nichts nicht ich
muss sagen ich habe vor noch keinen
blick auf die jetzt sage ich mal
das ist erstmal zweiten part noch leute
wenn ihr jetzt sagt alex auf jeden fall
zweiten tat lassen doch nach oben darf
dann setze ich mich genau jetzt wenn
dieses video online kommt und ich sehe
es kommt gut an hin und bestellen noch
verrücktere sachen sobald es gibt
wirklich jeden scheiß jetzt kommen wir
nämlich zum letzten produkt wobei ich
mich ein bisschen wunder ist fehlt
eigentlich noch ein weiteres pro zwei
weitere produkte häufig sogar ich hoffe
die kommentar gemahlen und ich kann das
noch mit rein nehmen ansonsten nehme ich
mal einfach dann in den zweiten part mit
rein der sowieso kommen will einfach
weil es mir selber spaß macht fest dass
man kurz hier mit der schnalle dann
kannst du dir also an die hose hängen
wobei da muss man ja auch was man das so
draußen rumhängt dass ihr da keiner die
kopfhörer ausgelaugt hast du schon mal
irgendwann in der bahn gesehen der dann
am flughafen es halt zum beispiel geil
wenn du deine tasche oder so packen kann
ja aber hast du schon mal jemanden
gesehen der airport capital auf suche
und per flex alles für den flex halb wie
viel ist ein auftritt wert ja dann habe
ich hier noch airports choir ich genau
dann kommen wir jetzt ein produkt ich
weiß dass das werden wahrscheinlich die
meisten von euch feiern so wollen die
die jüngeren kids unter euch und vor
allem die jungs sagen läuft dann so geil
bist du bereit ich muss sagen die sind
irgendwie alle gleich verpackt außer
dass das hier ist jetzt ein bisschen
hochwertiger natürlich nicht wir haben
hier eine ultimative mercedes-amg
airport case verpackung
wie auch immer das war ich wohl das mal
das ist doch so ein bisschen das hat so
eine raue oberfläche laufen deswegen ich
will das jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig aus
anni war so ein bisschen aus leder und
so
also wenn man damit in der schule hatte
das war noch der über king oder es ist
echt leder so viel mehr hier
das ist halt es ist jetzt wahrscheinlich
keine originale zu sehen das ist wieso
sand stoff aber es ist schon geil schon
geil gemacht gut
das war damals irgendwelche solche
schwarze 1 und 1 gestanden
schwarz oder weiß selbst die meisten
läufer hat ist gar nicht mal so leicht
wenn die erstmal irgendwo drin sind die
wieder rauszukriegen
ok jetzt habe ich es auch mal
rausgekriegt und also dass wir ein
bisschen eng obwohl erst geht das geht
ich glaub ich steh da wieder raus das
passt nicht ohne scheiß ich musste
gerade die einen airports da so
ausdrücken weil gegen ihn bis hin zu
groß waren und diese hier passt es
perfekt rein und schwarz kann man also
da muss ich sagen das ist eigentlich
schon mein favorit von allen wenn ich
jetzt selber mercedes hätte habe ich
nicht mehr bei bewusstsein
dann würde ich das jetzt so lassen aber
ich finde mercedes hat mittlerweile
jeder oder zumindest hat das berühmt
berüchtigte wie ip leasing von halb
youtube deutschland deswegen und mode
steht aber es hat mal wieder raus oder
ich bekomme das kann ich eigentlich
machen
ich fahr los jetzt einfach die
erzieherin und was auch immer das für
welche waren ich habe keine ahnung mit
der höhe zusammen so in dunklen bösen
schwarz auch auf instagram leute den
server alex w und das soll dann würde
ich sagen das war jetzt fünf klicks
richtig spaß gemacht leute wenn ihr mehr
findet oder so steht mir die auf jeden
fall auf instagram zu ich schaue selber
noch nach dem zweiten part aber nicht
den kanal wir sehen uns dann mal um 19
uhr wieder break even million und ja das
war es war sein